so in a convenient twist of fate the
indictment of former president Donald J
Trump came on the very same day that
members of the House oversight committee
viewed the FBI document the 1023 form
alleging that Joe Biden took bribes in
exchange for actions as vice president
Now sources that have seen the documents
tell Fox News digital that it details an
alleged 10 million dollar payment to Joe
and Hunter from a barisma executive the
executive apparently said that he would
route the payments through so many shell
companies that the transfer would take
at least 10 years to uncover it and what
did Barista this executive want in
exchange for that money well he wanted
to Halt an investigation into his
company by a prosecutor in Ukraine that
prosecutor is the one that Joe Biden
leveraged a billion taxpayer dollars and
demanded he'd be fired in six hours and
Son of a b they fired that guy yesterday
when asked about these serious
allegations President Biden he just
laughed him off take take a look
I'm supposed to walk off the stage
reallocation Congresswoman Nancy Mason
through standing evidence an FBI file
that he sold out the country do you have
a response to the Congressional
Republicans where's the money
Milwaukee
all right joining us now author of a
really good new book you can get it on
in bookstores all across the country uh
hannity.com amazon.com March for the
majority former Speaker of the House Fox
News contributor Newt Gingrich is with
us all right there are two things that
are Beyond puzzling to me one is you
know in the middle of Trump's
impeachment we have Joe Biden on tape
bragging that he leveraged one billion
dollars to get a Ukrainian prosecutor
fired and gave him six hours to do it
they fired him it turns out that that
prosecutor was investigating barisma and
it turns out the the prosecutor was
investigating Hunter Biden uh Hunter
Biden does an interview on GMA and
admits he has no experience in energy
oil gas coal or Ukraine now to me that
seems like a quid pro quo by Joe nobody
showed any interest in that Mr Speaker
why
look I I think all of us who were
conservative have misunderstood what's
going on
it's a lot like Hillary they didn't
prosecute Hillary because she's so
likable
they didn't prosecute Hunter because
after he's such a nice guy they're not
going to go after Joe because after all
he means well I mean what you have here
is Absolute Total corruption and I have
a couple simple tests frankly for the
House Republicans
um release the document it's not
classified there's no reason every
American can't read it put it on the
internet let all of us read remember
this is a confidential FBI informant who
the FBI believed did enough to have paid
him over two hundred thousand dollars
over the years so they thought he was a
very serious person so let's read what
he had to say second I just did a
newsletter at Gingrich 360 uh saying
that this is the wrong indictment the
Donald Trump indictment is wrong the
first indictments ought to be all the
people who were mentioned as Breaking
the Rules and Breaking the Law in the
Durham report those are FBI agents the
second indictment ought to be the two
universities that still haven't told us
how much money they got from the Chinese
Communists while taking care of the
bidens that's the University of Delaware
and the University of Pennsylvania in
the University of Pennsylvania got two
ambassadorships out of the deal and
there were 10 Biden administrations
senior people being paid by the
University of Pennsylvania with money
that I think came directly from
communist China the third indictments
ought to be the Biden family I mean how
can you have you know it's a very simple
just ask yourself
why would the Widow of the mayor of
Moscow send three million dollars to
Hunter Biden why would three and a half
hire a guy who clearly didn't know
anything uh three and a half million uh
I'm I'm glow-balling I'm trying to be
conservative uh why would why would but
think about it why would barisma be
paying him why would somebody in
Kazakhstan send him money why would a
Chinese billionaire be sending him a
diamond when and as chairman Comer
reported the other day we know of at
least one case where three million
dollars was sent to the Biden family
from China uh and finally what does it
tell you that apparently the FBI
leadership insisted that the IRS disband
the team that was looking into the money
for the bidens this whole thing is sick
and it puts in context what's happening
with Trump what you have is a deliberate
vicious effort worthy of Zimbabwe or
Venezuela or Cuba but then the United
States of America
to have this kind of totally ruthless
use of the power of the government you
know it's ironic this is the week that
is the anniversary of the publication of
George Orwell's 1984. and what we're
seeing is exactly the use of state power
that Orwell warned us against and I hope
that the Republicans next week will
release the document put it on the
internet let every American see it and
then ask the attorney general and the
head of the FBI how could you have had
this
for several years and not investigated
it I mean there's something profoundly
sick about this newt's folk marched the
majority by the way I had the honor of
actually interviewing him on his own
podcast about his new book uh bookstores
all around the country uh amazon.com
Newt 360 I believe is where the podcast
is Mr speaker thank you sir hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else